dan hayes covered the white sox for
comcast sports he joins us now dan good
morning how are you good morning have I
mom well what did you hear that
something was going on with Chris sale
in the in the locker room it's funny I
was I was off on saturday and and taking
a nap and my my phone blew up and
everybody thought that there was a trade
going on and that's the that's the funny
part about all this is that you know I
mean now we've got this point on social
media where a player something weird is
going on it's immediately you're in hug
watch mode has the guy been traded and
and it came two days after Rick on their
GM had come out and said hey we're open
to any idea right now because we've been
mired in mediocrity for a while we're
not going to do any short-term rentals
we're not going to do anything to
sacrifice our future we're going to go
out and just think about whatever and
that includes potentially trading sale
and cantana Jose cansada and really
those two guys it's going to take a lot
for them to do that but the same time
fans here that they expect oh man Chris
Sale could get traded and he's scratched
and first the word came out that maybe
it was the flu and and that's about when
I was alerted to it and it went an
entirely different direction than I
think everybody thought it would well
sale is an emotional guy when when adam
laroche it you know took his son and
went home you know sales stood up for
LaRoche and I mean is he you see the
leader there is he that kind of fiery
wearing his emotions on his sleeve
absolutely out from a pitcher side
obviously i mean he he is as much of a
leader as possible not in baseball
obviously the pitchers having a little
bit tougher because they fear only on
the field once every five times but you
know from from that perspective sale is
the guy that a lot of people look to
he's the longest-tenured guy here and
and he's got a lot of the he's carried
over a lot of the mark burleigh and Paul
Konerko White Sox way kind of thing and
and you know yesterday James Shields has
only been teammate for about seven weeks
now and shield said I've you know
only known this guy for a little bit as
a teammate but he's one of the best
teammates have ever had he stands up for
guys and I think the LaRoche thing made
him a kind of all time teammate when
when he did that I mean he went kind of
out there and took a stance for his
teammate and backed him and and you know
we know how kind of strange that whole
story was and and sale was unwavering in
that and so everybody respects him very
much right do we know what did he have a
nice did he have scissors how many
uniforms did he chop up those those
details are a little sketchy because I
couldn't even get a confirm from someone
within I had to go outside the
organization to get it confirmed and
Chris wasn't around yesterday and I've
never seen so few players in the
clubhouse when the media was available
it was media without number and players
about 20 22 and and you know Todd
Frazier has got to be one of the most
talkative guys in baseball and and he
was just very quiet about it and we got
shields to say that you know sales a
good teammate sometimes emotions get the
best of you but I heard scissors were
not the culprit for sure so it may have
been a knife I i don't know i was going
to do a Twitter poll yesterday on what
the potential object was but I decided
that was probably not in my best
interest so it it's definitely a little
bit of a crazy story does this impact
his trade the trade rumors not his value
he's got a great contract if you're
going to pick that up and he's been
lights out so is is sale going to get
traded I don't see it happening now it's
possible this offseason but but right
now you know they want a major league
player back amongst the package and you
know it's going to be hard for a team
like the Rangers or the Red Sox to give
you the star player back during a
pennant chase I could see that being
easier to attain during the off-season
when and also you'll get the full
complement teams right now the teams are
motivated the Dodgers the the Red Sox
and the Rangers and and those teams do
have some of the best farm systems but
at the same time I think you know you
look at that free agent mar
get and it's awful for pitchers I mean
rich hill's probably the best guy out
there and you throw Chris Sale out there
I mean you're probably going to get as
close to the price you can ask for at
that time so it wouldn't surprise me if
it was more the offseason I mean
anything could happen teams are
motivated right now but you know they
did want a Nomar Mazara or they'd want
someone like a bets or somebody like
that from the Red Sox somebody that
those teams are got a hard time parting
with with two months of the season ago
has anybody else complained about the
jerseys these throwback jerseys that
incensed sale there there's a lot of
talk to last year I mean this is the
second year that they wore them and and
so you know there was they were
uncomfortable last year and I know the
White Sox did some spent some time
trying to alter them again and make them
more comfortable one of the reports and
I couldn't get a confirmed to sail
wasn't around but one of the reports I
saw was that he had tried it on in
spring training when they introduced it
and he still wasn't happy with it and it
just happened to fall on his pitching
day so you know it all it just all kind
of happenstance that just fell like this
and and it ended up being a huge story
because you mentioned a robust chapman
in the rumors and the that's
overshadowed right now and you would
think that's the kind of final move to
the puzzle for the for the Cubs and and
right now all everybody's talking about
is Chris Sale in Chicago dan thanks for
joining us we appreciate it yeah thanks
for having me it's dan hayes-white
sonics insider for comcast sportsnet
chicago the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience